like this altitude for my hands this
episode is brought to you by Vimeo
specifically a new offering called Vimeo
business I've done a lot of
collaboration with these guys
Vimeo business has all of the prior
benefits of Vimeo Pro including VIP
support whether you make videos for a
living
run your own company like yours truly or
simply want to amp up your video
marketing video business is here to help
they have more than 280 million creators
and viewers worldwide and Vimeo business
makes it easier to share your videos
with a global audience and connect with
professional video makers to bring your
stories to life so if you need
assistance it's there you can also
upload up to 5 terabytes and store your
videos in one secure place you can add
up to 10 team members to your account
for easy collaboration and gather
feedback with seamless review tools you
can add clickable calls to action and
perhaps most interesting to me capture
email addresses directly in the player
this can help you generate leads and
drive conversion for whatever you are
trying to optimize say for a newsletter
or in fact a sales page of some type
video business helps you optimize your
videos by tracking viewer engagement and
drop-off so you can then modify your
approach or creative moving forward and
improve it and it connects to Google
Analytics for even more insights let's
check it out go to Vimeo comm forward
slash Tim 10 to save 10% on Vimeo
business that's vimeo.com /ti m-10
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as i mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
hello boys and girls lemurs and
squirrels this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show weird is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers and
tease out the habits routines morning
meditation practices favorite books
whatever it might be that you can use
and test in your own life one of my most
popular episodes to date was with Matt
Mullenweg
who is best known or thought of as the
lead developer of WordPress which now
powers more than 25% of the entire web
his CEO of automatic which is a
multi-billion dollar startup fully
distributed he loves tea
he loves tequila he loves Chicken
McNuggets he's an incredible guy very
good at using a keyboard layout known as
Dvorak as well we had a very very long
conversation you've all been asking for
a round two so in this episode he
answers your most popular questions and
which were uploaded online and you can
say hello to him online on Twitter at
fotomat that's photo ma TT so please
enjoy round 2 with Matt Mullenweg
all righty hello hello everybody this is
Matt Malek coming back to the amazing
Tim Ferriss podcast it's been she not
that long since I was last on him but
lots changed for me and the company when
I was last coming to y'all through that
conversation with Tim filled with much
tequila WordPress was about 23% of the
internet we've gone up to about 26 and a
half percent which I'm really happy
about and my company automatic has
changed a lot in the time too we were
about 300 people when I last spoke to
Tim and we actually just this week
passed 500 so things have grown a lot
but I am excited to be checking out some
of these questions you sent and and
that's him and Adam compiled and so yes
let's go ahead and dive in all righty
let's start from Steve Rubell he asked
what's the hardest part about running a
company with a distributed workforce one
that others perhaps don't fully consider
when trying the same you know a lot of
the how-to and technical sort of
logistics the tactics are running a
distributed company I think are getting
better and better you know we use zoom
for video conferencing and slack for
chats and P twos on WordPress for you
know instead of email and Google Apps
are really good so all the basic tools
are out there and they're getting better
every day so if in terms of being able
to communicate its really with one
person you can do that extremely high
fidelity almost instantly from wherever
you are in the world with internet
connection I think there's still
challenges in terms of getting a group
of people on the same page however I
don't perceive those challenges to be
that much different from what people who
work in the same office are and so they
you know I talked to friends with
startups of a similar size to automatic
you know four or five hundred people
they typically spread across a couple
floors in a building or camp
and they talk about how you know they
have to repeat themselves a lot and and
it's sort of really honing messages and
do town halls and all these sorts of
things to get everyone in the company on
the same page so I think that just might
be something difficult about groups or
scaling organizations that as soon as it
goes above you know what could be in one
or a couple of people's heads there's a
drifter that happens between how
different people imagine what a goal is
the thing I found best for that even
though it wasn't your question is to
have some sort of prototypes or mock-ups
or there's an Amazon thing where when
they're working at starting a new
project they write the press release for
it you know the idea or I would call it
write the blog post for it so write what
the announcement will look like when you
tell the world about this
so techniques and that you know low
fidelity mock-ups can really help make
sure everyone's thinking about the same
thing when you use the same words which
is surprisingly difficult but finally
the thing I'll say that is hard about
distributed that's not talked about and
that I think I uniquely appreciate right
now because once a year the entire
company of automatic comes together we
do it we call it our grand meetup as
opposed to the normal meetups which
teams do individually and are usually
like five to ten people the grand meet
up we bring the whole company and this
year it was in Whistler British Columbia
up in Canada so we had about four
hundred and sixty people out of the 500
there and it was incredible like it's
pretty much like my favorite week of the
year people are so different and
everyone's weird in their own ways and
unique and has crazy hobbies and a
couple days before I actually did over
landing with two colleagues across from
Calgary to Whistler so we were off-road
and doing crazy things and jeeps and
then there's a band where people play
together
everyone goes flash talks so like little
miniature of five minute talks about a
topic they're interested in so the
aftermath of that is that I think the
thing about being distributed is that it
can be a little lonely
like I really love my colleagues I love
spending time with them I love learning
about them I love talking to them and
it's true that in person is still the
best
you know way to connect with someone it
virtual has gotten better but there's
you know so many more senses that are
engaged in ways you can read people and
you can share a drink or break bread or
share food you know when you're in
person that just we don't in have
virtual equivalents before yet and so I
think that's one of the hardest things
assuming you like your colleagues you
miss them and it can be a bit lonely and
so one thing I always encourage
especially when younger folks you know
maybe straight out of college join
automatic is to make sure you have a
good social life outside of work because
sometimes we default getting that human
connection and that engagement from you
know our colleagues and that's not a bad
thing at all and I'm a little jealous of
folks who go to an office every day with
awesome people who get to do that but
when you don't have that it's important
to develop that social network outside
of it and so it's one of the reasons I
love hanging with Tim or other friends
in San Francisco when I'm there you know
a lot of my when I'm in Houston it's a
lot of my friends from high school and
family so making sure you have that
social layer to support you and keep you
connected with the world so you don't
become a weird hermit all right next
question
Jeffrey McLeod now that you have many
hours of travel and work under your belt
what used to be annoying experience and
annoying experience with working on the
road that you have adapted to or
overcome hmm
so travel wise I would say two of the
coolest things you could do as a
traveler is especially if you're USS is
get pre-check it's a total GameChanger
and I think this is related if there's a
program called Global Entry that lets
you bypass all the custom lines when
you're reentering the US and not all the
customs lines all the immigration lines
and just go straight to this machine
that scans your fingerprints and just
breeze on through you feel like you're
in the future it's amazing
so that definitely whenever I go through
the pre-check line or the Global Entry
line
I just feel amazing well it doesn't make
I don't know if it's totally rational
but it feels really good
the thing that's probably changed the
most over the few years of just
connectivity you can have an LTE
connection in the u.s. pretty much
everywhere and when I'm international I
use a Google Phi which is kind of a cell
phone service from Google that works in
over a hundred countries and ten bucks I
gave gigabytes or if I'm gonna be in a
country for a longer period of time
sometimes is cheaper just buy a local
SIM card but once you have that LTE
connection you don't have to worry about
Wi-Fi anymore because you can tether to
your computer
you'd have to worry about like there's a
coffee shop I'm an offer this or there's
my hotel have I mean hotels are the
worst for a Wi-Fi the more expensive the
hotel the worse it is - you could stay
in like a motel 6 and they have like
fast and free Wi-Fi and then I'm in like
a ritz-carlton and they want to charge
me 15 or 20 bucks a day for it and it's
so slow so just that mobile connectivity
I think has changed because any place
that I have my backpack and an internet
connection I can be fully productive I
can you know have my keyboards my mice
my headphones everything and I can work
just as if I'm at my desk at home and
connect with autumn atisha and just do
my job I have to do a CEO so that is the
thing that has definitely helped me the
most I also I'm constantly updating Zoar
the kits of what's in my backpack that
is my kind of superhero bag everything I
have I do a blog post all this once a
year if you just search for an O
Mullenweg what's in my bag you'll see
them and I'm sure Tim can link of the
notes as well so that changes every year
and yeah check that out check out that
blog post
another one from Jeffrey as he says if
you could start from scratch with what
you knew now what part of growth
personal professional would you have
emitted or asked for more of I think on
the professional end I just emphasize
that hiring and being thoughtful Benari
is the best way to scale an organization
and I feel like that's one of the things
that Tim usually has that's a question
which is super power I don't remember
what I said last time but if I were to
answer it today and say it's hiring you
know um I've done it now enough and
looked at enough resumes and everything
that and we have a process of automatic
which is tries to remove a lot of the
bias from things that you know you gave
the right people around the table and it
makes all the difference in the world um
what I would tell my younger self to
avoid professionally is probably sounds
a little tricky so oh that's one thing I
forgot after the podcast with Tim and
before now I'll automatically ended up
doing another round of funding we raised
about 160 million dollars maybe that was
before I don't recall exactly but um so
that funding has really transformed with
the areas that were able to move into
the things were able to work on and I
think I would I think previous points in
automatics history we were capital
constrained and that held back our
growth the growth of automatic with a
wordpress of it oh the other thing that
really been learning a lot that I would
tell my younger self is to think about
marketing I've always been kind of like
a yeah you build it they will come and
be honest for most of my career that's
worked I'm now starting to appreciate
more and more how marketing and getting
your message out there in the right way
it wasn't that WordPress didn't do it
before is that we did a lot of it and
didn't really think about it we kind of
lucked our way into it and I think being
systematic and approaching that with as
much care as you would you know the
pixels in the design or how an interface
works or how the architecture of the
code is is really crucial to a great
product
it's one of those fundamental tenants
and bases of a product that resonates
with lots of people so on the personal
life I probably tell myself to start
meditating more you know all the basic
stuff meditate exercise eat well
boring stuff I'm sure you've heard on
every single podcast tim has done and
more more on the personal side I would
say that learning to be vulnerable and
sensitive was something that especially
when I was younger I was like I go to
the world show no weakness especially
you know because I was young and I was
often not operating in with people who
were decades older than me or getting
investment or I thought I had to be like
invincible or put on this air of
invincibility of course no one is
invincible as a leader and actually
through meditation I become a lot more
empathetic and uh you know part of that
isn't just understanding and feeling
other people's emotions but really being
willing to show your own weaknesses and
emotions and be vulnerable you know I
think it's been a Browns book daring
greatly talks about this really well or
Krista Tippett on becoming wise another
great book these things well that I'll
just leave it at that
those are some good areas for listeners
of the podcast who have maybe done all
the stuff from for our body and for a
work week and are thinking about growing
this a little more it might be some good
avenues to investigate James clamat
asked what's the most important skill
set for an entrepreneur to develop what
characteristics do you look for when
recruiting new employees there's another
question that I think is a little
related to this Leo Harris D Marcos de
Manos says what are some skills you look
for and non-technical people so I'm
going to tie that into the recruiting
question so important skills of an
entrepreneur to develop resilience you
know a balance where you can maintain
your health both mental and physical
while working really really really
hard and exactly I just talked about
empathy and actually just yesterday I
saw an amazing presentation from Julia
hearts who is the CEO of Eventbrite
whereas she really spoke about this as a
lesson that she's learned over the past
few years where being vulnerable and
showing empathy is one of the things
that's helped her most as a CEO which is
so counterintuitive
so I say those skills are very important
also just the basics if you're an
entrepreneur you know learn about term
sheets learn about preferences learn
about all the mechanics of your business
know enough accounting that you can talk
to your accountant know enough
development that you can talk to your
developers know enough marketing you
talk to your marketers you have to be
know at least a bit about really every
part of your business because that'll
allow you to hire and recruit people
that really understand it I mean of
course you want them to understand it
way way better than you but by having
even just a common vocabulary that you
can converse with that person in you'll
be able to operate with them at a much
higher level than if you were just a
complete novice and their given area of
expertise and by the way you can also
have them teach you it's an amazing way
to grow these skills I rely on our ops
team an automatic very very heavily you
know they that's one of the things we're
doing really lucky about is everything
with HR and Finance and legal and
everything they're just super top-notch
and able to learn a ton from them and
don't have to worry about that which has
been amazing so the characteristics you
look for in recruiting new employees and
the what do you look for non-technical
people question really here and as a
saying is a basketball guy and he was
like you know you can't coach tall so
for the qualities I look for are the
things that you can't really teach and
that's work ethic taste integrity and
curiosity if you think about all of
those if someone has those four things
work ethic taste integrity and curiosity
I believe that you can learn pretty much
anything in the world if you look at any
spirts this is something that I think is
good to remember like if you look at
Elon Musk on space rockets our Tim Mont
health and fitness and well all the
things that was an expert on or any of
these different areas like remember that
at one point that person knew nothing
about it well all born we all learn and
so I really do truly believe that you
can become an expert in any field if you
put in the hours and the work and the
practice and everything so if someone
has those four things I know that they
will be able to rise to whatever the job
and role requires of them and of course
we look for experience and such in order
to shortcut that process a little bit
but I also know that for every person I
hire at automatic what we're doing today
and what they're hired for is likely not
going to be what we're doing five or ten
and certainly not twenty or thirty years
from now and when we hire I do it with
the expectation that someone's gonna be
in the company for decades to come
it's not just a short stint it's it's
something that's really a long-term
relationship it's like getting married
and so you I think about not just where
they are today but how will they adapt
when the company changes and when the
world changes and when we're all you
know in the singularity itself those
sort of intrinsic and tough to teach
things become more and more important
next question comes from Rock'em fart if
WordPress is the platform of writing and
Shopify is of commerce the other should
similar platforms you think are worth
developing that's a good question there
are a few areas that I think um are sort
of like fundamentals for interaction on
the web that there aren't great open
source tools for yet or in some cases
good tools in general one area that's
getting a ton of investment now that
even though there aren't you know
perfect open source things I think we're
in a pretty good place is just messaging
so
between slack and you know the Facebook
Facebook's making the messenger telegram
whatsapp messaging built into platforms
like Instagram and all this like I feel
like that's the communication side of
things is being pretty well and Festiva
but then what do you think about how
communication happens online there's
still so much to do there so for example
we actually have something we're
reviving a little bit called bleakie
which is the combination of a blog and a
wiki I basically the idea that wiki's
are pretty cool but you lose when you
have everyone being able to edit
everything you lose some of the elements
of moderation or curation that make many
websites great so public is essentially
something in between that it's a
moderated wiki so anyone can edit it but
the edits go through a moderation queue
much like the comments on WordPress go
through our moderation queue that can be
accepted or denied so you can get kind
of the best of both worlds of community
participation and and you know sort of
the curation and editorial direction
that comes from great websites and blogs
so I think wiki's are an area that needs
some innovation forms as well
if forums are so much fun and I learned
a lot of what I've done and had lots of
great conversations on forums I know Tim
has as well I know like it's kind of all
these things that is forms aren't really
sexy so no one talks about them and
looks at them we have a product called
BB press there that we use for the
support forums on wordpress.org
wordpress.com and it's used by some
other folks that's definitely an area
I'd like to invest more into and that
platform I think that needs to be a
better platforms for and then you
mentioned Commerce and Shopify Shopify
is an incredible tool
commerce is action area we've moved into
we did an acquisition of a platform
called WooCommerce which is built on top
of WordPress and I think that commerce
you know from anyways but commerce were
where blogging was in 2007-2008 where
there's some great hosted tools and as
some great open source tools like
WooCommerce but if you want to use
WooCommerce
you probably need to be a little more
tech savvy or have a developer and we're
entering the area much like where
WordPress was in 2008 where we're
starting to make it so anyone can use
the software so you get kind of the best
of the ease of use of one of the
platforms but the flexibility of having
complete control over your domain the
code everything you can customize it I
think that's a winning combination and I
hope that over the next couple of years
WooCommerce can live up to its uh you
know fantastic competitors in the
marketplace including Shopify ecwid big
commerce etc so finally I'd say that
yeah you said we're the platform of
writing and a very flat and flat earth
there but still the blogging and
especially with comments I think that
there's so so so much more to do so uh
you just got me really excited to get
back to work so I always want to stop
the podcast and go talk to some teams
around WordPress not Ematic so that's a
good question it got me pretty yeah you
know the toughest thing the idea with
day-to-day it's a lot of stuff I just
talked about outside of whoo which were
making huge investments in our ideas we
had sometimes even five or ten years ago
that because the opportunities with our
main business lines which are WordPress
jetpack and WooCommerce are so huge that
it's tough we have to focus in on them
and there were years and maybe this goes
back to something I would tell my
earlier self professionally some early
years of automatic we diluted ourselves
we spread ourselves too thin and so we
really had to say no to a lot and that's
how I understand is that famous Steve
Jobs or Johnny Ives lion-like
you know a great product to say no to a
thousand things I used to think that was
like a thousand buttons and you say no
to 999 of them and now it resonates me
more saying that you know in addition to
these things were focused on there's
like 999 other things I would love to be
working on like areas I'd love to like
tackle and its really saying no not to
even just a feature of the product but
they're working on other products
entirely
and some other things that makes me
excited about scaling automatic from 500
people today to 5000 in the future is
that we can do our core areas really
really well and make sure that those
continue to be the best in the world but
also expand the breadth of what we work
on so right next question this is from
I'm going to say Jocko timonin timonin
and I apologize for everyone's names I'm
doing my best to pronounce them and and
just sent me a tweet or something
afterwards that I could do it better
says and this actually relates to the
saying no that 999 things what has been
the most important default setting in
you that you've been that you've later
questioned and remove by default setting
I mean a value or behavior that's been
hardwired by parents environment
education or society you know I think
it's almost just more than a specific
default setting but I probably have some
things I do differently like I typed it
a Vorik live instead of it the QWERTY
layout or you know just a living
distributed versus living in a home or
being in one place or building companies
in a different way it's just the fact
that you're constantly looking at the
fault settings
so I'd say Jaco by this question they're
probably thinking about it the right way
because my default settings and what you
know the way I grew up in society and
everything like that is going to be
different from yours and so the things
that need to change will be different
and our situations are different so what
you should think about is just asking
yourself that question at various
intervals and this is why I love kind of
the Christmas New Year's time because it
forces you to take a step back and kind
of look from the 10,000 feet view but I
try to do this it's actually something
that happens a lot when I'm trying to
meditate and I can't quiet my mind and
I'm thinking of lots of things sometimes
I'll just take a pause and be like okay
I'm just gonna not meditate but also not
do anything not look at my phone not do
anything have a piece of paper and just
to see everything that's caught up in my
mind and how do I where do I think
that's going how do I think it's sort of
unwind my mind in terms of what what's
what's stuck in there and what are the
things I'm thinking about it often leads
me to take that step back from the
day-to-day and look at things from
abroad or since is my life heading in
the right direction on my relationships
in the right place were the people that
I love and care about but maybe haven't
spoken to and a few weeks or a few
months or maybe even all year so those
sort of steps back I think cause you to
look at your own operating system and
actually something I think that
meditation is great for that is like
almost like an interrupt I read a cool
book called up this is called search
within yourself and it was it's a fellow
at Google that started a I think it's
even called search within yourself
meditation and mindfulness program I
believe his name was a Jade Ming Tom and
he talks about he's kind of an
engineering background and also Googler
sorry the book is I think pretty cool
for leaders of companies because it
talks about the business benefits of
mindfulness and from an engineering
point of view how mindfulness and
meditation is almost kind of like a
background process that runs and then
whenever you know the your operating
system throws up a interrupt like a
reaction or a motion to things it can
kind of catch that and so before you
immediately react and do the thing that
would be sort of your first intuition or
reaction to an emotion or other thoughts
it says hey wait a second and that's
essentially the muscle you're developing
when you meditate and when I started
thinking of it that way I was like wow
okay so just like I might do a plank or
push-ups or something like I need to
work this muscle every day if I can
and I think it's impossible to do that
and not think about your default
settings or you know go back to the
first principles of why you do things
the reason why you got into what you do
in the first place are you truly happy
these are tough questions but one is
that and ones that you can honestly with
the distraction of day-to-day life and
our phones and our blogs and social
media it is so easy to just be lost
minute to minute and be busy all day and
not really bring yourself closer to the
mountain that you want to climb so I
would say if you are listening right now
maybe you emboss and just take 10
minutes whether you're driving in the
car or whatever you're doing just pause
the podcast and like do nothing have
zero inputs and just think about that
you know alright I guess we're back now
next question is from Matthew Arnold
hard work in and of itself does not seem
the guarantee success it's true there
are plenty of truly hard-working
entrepreneurs whose businesses will fail
- what other factors besides hard work
do you attribute you massive success in
business luck good mentors timing all
right Matthew which is an awesome name
thank you for that question I think you
know it's definitely oh it's funny that
when people call me successful I don't
think of myself as that way and I think
part of that even though I know
objectively by many measures I have been
and I've been an extraordinary fortunate
and lucky and everything but part of its
because I fail so often so I don't think
that you know yes you know if you ten
businesses restored today nine of them
will fail by the way including if I did
them so it's just it's not how many
times you fall it's how many times you
get back up is really key and people
talk about resilience on all these
things so that is true and even like I
think of business icons and like the
greatest companies of our time Facebook
has products that fails all the time
they launched poke like a snapchat
ripoff you know Amazon which I am a huge
admirer of Jeff Bezos do you member the
Kindle phone that was just like
here that was a huge failure and not
just a huge trailer like one that they
must have spent the better part of a
billion dollars on so like we don't stop
failing it's just you want to hopefully
design your systems to assume failure
and have some backup plans a plan B a
Plan C a plan D all the way to a plan Z
so that you'll you'll be able to you
know get up and fight another day and
just that um just whatever that drives
you to do it you know I think having a
higher motivation beyond the extrinsic
things which might be come from success
so something more than money something
more than material goods that motivates
you is really key and yeah so that's
that's kind of the thing that I would
attribute it to that uh especially in
business press we just see when people
hit the homeruns we don't see all their
at-bats and very rarely do do we even
know about all that bats they've had so
just remember that no matter how bad a
day you think you're having there's
probably someone you admire who's
probably also having a bad day right
this second and and you're not alone
next up Julianne Bosley you have 30
minutes before the end of the world you
find yourself in a very well-stocked bar
next to an amazingly very delicatessen
what choice of food and drink did you
enjoy I liked this question a lot
because well I love food and drink I'm
actually on a quest right now to go to
all the top 50 restaurants on the world
this allistic is published I think by
Pellegrino responsibly Pellegrino and
I've been to nine of the top ten and I
think yeah about 40 45 percent of the
top 50 so I you know I think well these
experiences from these chefs which it's
like it's a whole out of the world thing
but I love food and drink now usually
when I'm drinking part of why I like
this question is you know there's 30
minutes before that in the world
generally when I engage in libations I
try to stick to the same alcohol all
night this is just something I've
learned from like trial and error mostly
error is that when I mix when I mix
different types of alcohols I feel kind
of terrible
I heard of saying once that drinking is
borrowing happiness from tomorrow but
that's true when it's sent especially if
you mix but if I stay with one you know
if I stay with a great cost of joy bonus
all night or wine all night or whiskey
all night I say those are my three
favorites of course to a reasonable
degree you have too much of anything is
bad for you I'm typically pretty okay
the next day but the truth is is that I
love all sorts of different drinks and
there's great drinks made from gin and
rum and other things great cocktails
that I would love to have but I
typically avoid because like I don't
want to drink gin all night so for the
drinking part of things I would
basically have like a bunch of
everything at the bar and just enjoy it
preferably in some great cocktails um in
terms of a wine I would you know have a
great I actually love California wines
to some great old California wines like
an apple Omega or just some of the
classics and for basically the last
thing I'm going to assume this
delicatessen has a foie gras and I know
this is so bougie I can't believe I'm
saying this but like there's an
experience that wasn't like Flom notes
on your tongue and then you wash it down
with like a great satire and like a
chateau de Kim it's just the best one
that the bar has ah it is a party in
your mouth like it's almost impossible
to describe the sensation of what goes
on there with those two those two tastes
interacting so that would be like 29
minutes and 45 seconds to think I would
I would have and then otherwise from the
delicatessen I probably should go for a
good snack a couple good sandwiches you
know it's definitely like a like eggs
and cheese and bacon on a croissant is a
go-to that always gives me joy
and that's funny and we're coming up on
Thanksgiving and everything's giving him
like man jerky is so good why don't I
eat more turkey and especially know
those day after turkey sandwiches we
have like the pulled turkey like the
dark meat then he gets like mayonnaise
cranberry and horseradish and just like
kind of mix up the sandwich a lot
pickles lots of pickles maybe something
like I even like try to mix in like some
sauerkraut or some kimchi like something
fermented in there that would probably
be like my I go to super good deli
sandwich so Julian thank you because
this question was super fun for me I
have to think about because I really
want a lot of different directions so
there's some mixed cocktails some good
wine and then ending it out with a great
sun turn all right next question
we've got Alexander Francesco Newman
Matt what are your thoughts on
artificial intelligence web developer
designers tools such as the grid or Wix
Adi a wordpress use some sort of AI
developer or designer feature in the
future or just an AI um this is kind of
funny I don't like to talk bad about
competitor so I won't mention any
specifically but I do think that right
now there's kind of a almost like a
completely vaska's marketing hype cycle
around AI that has nothing to do with
artificial intelligence at all and so
people are just slapping AI on
everything like maybe before they
slapped like cloud on stuff for that
just isn't AI at all so I think it's
religious marketing and that thing I've
seen in the marketplace so far is much
more than vaporware and a good demo so I
do think that essentially what they come
down as kind of wizards it's not that
much different from like what a clippie
would do and like Microsoft Word in the
90s so I think there's much better
approaches to that sort of problem now
embedded and that is do I think that
this changes we can make to WordPress
that would
get easier for folks to get going or get
started or you know the thing I think
about which is really our biggest
challenge and the thing I work on every
day which is how do you connect bridge
that gap between what someone imagines
and what they're able to create so
absolutely that's what we work on every
day big parts of automatic work on how
do we make it easier and more intuitive
to have that effortless flow as you're
building things and that is at the core
of what we do in terms of AI and sort of
that impacting the business I think that
we're still a few or many years away
from that being more useful then
interface a well-designed traditional
interface an extra really great essay
about this we'll find the link for the
show notes but essentially there's a
fellow who looked at all the chat bots
which are sort of an area of AI right
now that for messenger for telegram
there's these BOTS and you can say hey I
want a pizza they're like what kind of
pizza do you want mm how about some
pepperoni or maybe it's smart so it says
hey you usually get pepperoni do you
want some pepperoni you know like yeah
let me have some pepperoni but I'll darn
it's not my cheat day so deliver it on
Saturday instead you know you sort of
have like this conversational interface
that sometimes people call AI with with
this product or service that you consume
or buyer and interact with and basically
what this essay does is is it compares
that model to what a lot of folks in the
u.s. are trying to copy which is the
success of platforms like WeChat in
China
it shows how these days we chat actually
it's not that you're purely chatting
with someone and asking them which
sounds to me like you know the
inconvenience of calling a restaurant to
get a reservation versus using like a
reserved or an open table to just click
a few buttons and get one you know that
we chat really embeds these interfaces
and he talks about the number of taps it
takes to you know chat with
but to get something versus the taps I
think it maybe even uses a pizza sample
to order a pizza in China on WeChat do
this make a conversational platform I
think that that's one of the areas where
you know like a great interface can
still surpass a chat one thing that
we're doing so I'll give you all kind of
a preview of something we're working on
for WordPress comm is we actually are
working on a new chat interface so we
provide for paying customers live chat
support and you know it's a great
experience you're connected with a real
live human being and and they will help
you through whatever you're having
trouble with so it's basically like you
know it's real intelligence it's much
better than artificial intelligence they
can help you with anything and there's
some disadvantages though in terms of
you know it's difficult to scale in
terms of we're hiring people as fast as
we can very happy with happiness
engineers automatic but we want to
create tools that enable them to just
reach more people so we're going on this
new chat system and the two big things
that changes are one it abstracts out
who you're talking to
because right now and by the way I do
live chat support sometimes too so if
you're chatting and you have maybe three
or four chats going on simultaneously
you're helping people it's a little bit
difficult both to wrap those up like
let's say you want to go to lunch but
even things like using the restroom you
know you don't want to leave the people
you're chatting with hanging because
they're waiting for you
so by abstracting that so you're
basically be chatting with like you know
an agent or a cartoon character or
whatever it is that we decide instead of
a specific person we can allow
transferring of chats between people way
easier behind the scenes so you know you
could have a I'm going to the bathroom
button or you know my my dog just you
know started chewing on the couch button
and the chats could be transferred to
someone that gets all the transcripts
and everything and could just pick it up
it instantly and and keep the chat going
invisibly to the person they're
traveling with but to is we're lurking
at now this is an area I like way more
than artificial
which is machine learning so we now have
all of the chats I mean this point
probably close to a million interactions
we've done over way more than a million
emails chats everything so we can apply
and you know I'm gonna say a buzz word
deep learning which I'm gonna say is not
totally hide because it's been some
amazing open source tools released by
Google like tensorflow and like a lot of
the technology is actually pretty useful
here to learn from those and essentially
augments the happiness engineers the
people doing support by when we get
something that looks a lot like what
we've seen before we can suggest
essentially like a pre reply like an
answer for them that saves them having
to type out or do everything and then
they can customize that or use that to
augment their ability to chat with folks
so this has been a pretty cool project
in the area where I think AI could
actually have a real impact versus just
being marketing I'm Hemet Fadi for asked
if you hadn't accomplished what you've
accomplished and started over with
nothing but the next six months of your
life look like this is a pretty quick
tricky question because there's a lot of
ways to think about it I think the first
way I thought about it was well if I
just lost all of my like I lost
everything like I had to declare
bankruptcy and had no assets or anything
that I mean the obvious thing I have
lots of friends and family so that would
be that's sort of my safety net so I
would you know probably maybe move back
in home and start to rebuild from there
but that's probably not how you intended
it and hopefully like unless the
question is if you don't have friends
and family that you think would take you
in if you were having a hard time
develop some deeper relationships you
never know what's gonna happen and by
the way that means that you will take
them and if they're having a hard time
it's totally reciprocal so um then as a
version of this question I've seen
before were like what if you knew
everything you know but you're you're
homeless one day and you know so you
lose everything and you don't have any
friends or family you can sort of fall
back on so you're kind of alone
but you have higher knowledge what would
you do my answer there again and this
mail also assumes yes the privilege of
being in the United States and things
like that is I would probably go to the
external version of friends and family
which is maybe a church or YMCA or you
know whether nonprofits that tries to
help out people with nothing and sort of
use that as a home base to then develop
the other version of this die I thought
of was well what if you know instead of
all that you have your house you have
like you don't need to worry about
surviving but you are starting something
brand new so the thing I would do first
here so I know everything I know now I
would use my craft you know engineering
or music there's actually get a job so I
think I would probably look for the most
interesting company I could get access
to and just do my best to be hired there
you know create a really great
application really craft learn a lot
about their business and go into the
interviews knowing a little about it I'm
trying to stand out if they say no you
know keep trying to be hired and and
really put the just to try to get around
a great group and have a great job where
I know learn and can start to save and
develop the net for which I could do
something more entrepreneurial in the
future if I wanted to which i think is
what you're getting out with the
question so I get this job
there's a saying when I was a musician
is like you know you never want to be
the best musician in the band ideally or
the worst musician in the band because
that means you're learning from every
single person around you so try to find
a company or a group or someplace where
I could be the worst musician in the
band we're just every single person was
so much better than me ah I still made
the cut to make it in but then I would
just be learning from everyone around me
every day if I was just trying to start
something new and it couldn't be related
to anything I was done before so it
couldn't be content management or
e-commerce or you know any of the areas
that WordPress kind of plays in I think
what I would try to do is like figure
out the zeitgeist so you know
by a copy of the New Yorker in New York
Magazine and The Economist and wired and
Fast Company and I just read them cover
to cover maybe for a month or two maybe
get some back issues and try to figure
out what area is in that like the good
part of the hype cycle so something like
VR or AI is probably in the bad part of
the hype cycle where the expectations
people have for are so out of line and
like we're just early too early in terms
of the impact that the technology can
have so I try to look for an area that
is no longer maybe I would go back like
three or four years on those magazines
and look for something that was hot then
but no one's talking about now that's
probably where the biggest opportunities
are so the thing that everyone was
excited about five six seven years ago
it got a ton of you know over
investments and companies have started
and failed and now it's at that point in
the cycle where the real stuff is
happening like kind of the carpetbaggers
and the folks who are just in it for
money have all like come and gone and
it's just the people who really want to
make a difference in the world are still
there and working some ways I think
content management is in this area right
now or a lot of the hype was four or
five six years ago but now or actually
we can scale and having an impact on
hundreds of millions of people's lives
and that's where the big opportunity is
it might be you know outside of the web
areas like CRISPR gene editing some of
the bio stuff I think is getting pretty
interesting we're approaching times when
you know devices cell phones are
probably some mobile stuff is probably
in this area right now where you know we
have more than a billion mobile devices
no one's really thinking oh I'm going to
start a app but I kind of was one of the
most interesting start to app when
WordPress started the biggest criticism
was that there are too many blogging
systems in the world didn't need another
one so that was that would be what I
would try to find is like what is the
what do people say the world doesn't
need another one off because there's
plenty of it and then try it out carlos
rial
where do you see the future of the
Internet in terms of user behaviors
given that twenty years ago people
started to use and visit websites now
most people just use their phones and
when VR becomes useful it's likely we
all live on a VR platform the phone will
fall like the desktop hmm so my hope is
that phones don't fall like the desktop
because even in a world where the VR is
super amazing and we'll all be plugged
into the matrix I still really hope that
you know I can go on a hike with Tim or
if I get out in the world and see some
of the beautiful things all around us in
nature and in cities and in you know
instruments live and concerts and things
like that so when I'm mobile something
like a phone hopefully will be on me and
I hope that's still there so in terms of
the Internet's I think the behavior
that's changing the most is still just
as megatrend that we're still writing
we're you know the six billion people
still coming online so everything that
we think is amazing and huge and big now
is going to you know six x or more
likely ten or 100x where it is in terms
of user interaction in terms of post per
day in terms of number of people
tweeting like all of this is gonna be so
so so so much bigger than even the
already amazing levels it has reached
and as people become more comfortable
being native online like the same cycles
that people listening this podcast I
remember about 15 years ago we're like
you were nervous to put your credit card
online or things like that you know
folks coming online for the first time
we're gonna have those same nervousness
and go through the same hopefully
accelerated learning process of like you
know what's it like to truly live
digitally and live online so I think
that that will be adopted faster I also
hope that payments will be an area we
can have a lot of innovation because the
friction of payments I think puts us in
business models like advertising right
now which aren't the best you know how
cool would it be that everyone listening
to this I could give
instead of Tim having advertising or you
know doing whatever he needs to do he
could everyone listen this could just
put in a dollar or maybe even not a
dollar maybe put in like two pennies
some sort of micropayments that could
support creators all over the world
right now the payment systems that we
have just aren't set up for that but I
could imagine something like that being
really cool in the future ah the thing
that I think is gonna have to change
user behavior wise is we need to develop
more antibodies more immunity because
the technology is gonna get better and
better and better at engaging us machine
learning and in the future twenty years
now when we do have something more or
approaching artificial intelligence
could entertain us perfectly and keep us
always connected and engaged with
whatever companies want us to be engaged
with you know because a lot of this will
be commercially driven so that worries
me a little bit it's a little more brave
new world the 1984 and reminds me of
that great it's that great intro to I
think brave the world
I know it's Neil postman and I think he
wrote a book called amusing ourselves to
death and there was an insert we'll put
it in the show notes that someone made
into a comic that was a pretty amazing
in terms of like well 1984 predicted
would be our oppressors like Big Brother
and what actually is our oppressors
which looks more like brave new world
which is just we're kind of like the
title the book amusing ourselves to
death we're so caught up in distractions
and and pleasure and entertainment that
we might be missing out on the bigger
things so just like it took kind of the
world a hundred years to develop
antibodies to an addictive technology
like tobacco and cigarettes I think that
we need to develop antibodies to
technology addiction and the addiction
of really engaging experiences Nathan
Aaron says with all these web
development boot camps opening up is a
future demand for web developers still
high or stagnating I've actually been
really impressed with other boot camps
and especially in contrast to how
prepared people coming out of these boot
camps are
compared to people coming out of
four-year universities or colleges so I
think that universities and colleges
need to really up their game and adapt
if they're gonna still be something that
people think is a good investment
the just a tip for people who are going
through or thinking about going through
one of those hack camps or things the
thing that I still see I'm actually
reviewed I was looking at the other day
I reviewed 22,000 applications and
resumes to automatic in the past three
years so I look at a lot of these and
the all the web development web bootcamp
ones seem to follow a little bit of a
template so see if you can break out of
that a little bit but also even though
you might do projects as part of that I
don't the thing missing is often just a
little more experience and you say well
I don't have a job yet how do I get
experience open source contribute to
open source get involved with the open
source project that's something that I
think would because you're competing
with folks who maybe have three or four
years at Google or Facebook and things
like that and you might be just as good
from a development point of view but you
need to get some of that experience in
so the hack the the cool shortcut there
is get involved with the open source
project or start one and show sort of
real-world users real world
collaboration with other people and I
think I talked about that earlier and
the things I look for but you know the
most brilliant person in the world most
greatest developer the greatest anything
that can't work with other people is
basically not not ever going to have an
impact and honestly someone I would let
go of automatic now it doesn't matter
how great you are if you're not going to
be able to work within the context of a
team you know it's not someone who I
want to work with personally so being
able to show that in your application I
think is really key and the growth for
web developers I think is gonna grow
hugely but it'll also become more
sophisticated even think about you know
pre in the 90s before something like
WordPress you might need to call your
web developer every time you want to
change your website now tools like
WordPress make it easy for you do do
that all day long without talking anyone
so the basics are going to get easier
and easier because the software will
enable people to do that so what they
need developers for is we're going to
become more sophisticated I talked about
earlier that you know WordPress you can
start to make a great site if you're
gonna use WooCommerce you can definitely
get started with it but maybe to
customize it how you want you need to
developer so that's where the demand for
developers is growing so you need to
become more and more sophisticated as
the general world becomes more
sophisticated we got Tom Tron and Hmong
Tron among considering the heights
you've reached how do you motivate
yourself on a daily basis over the
course of any projects ah you know I'm
actually really lucky I just got two
Awards in the past few weeks
one was a fortune 40 under 40 which I
guess is a recognition not an award and
that other was the Heinz award which is
I'm really super honored by it's kind of
like the MacArthur Genius grant or
something they are the big five people
for per year in different areas and it
comes with a $250,000 grant and it's a
huge honor they're really looking like
I'm even blown away that I was
considered for it and so the win it was
that was very humbling but when these
things happen when this recognition
comes in or like you put it a height
you've reached this is a new height I've
reach if anything it makes me work
harder because I'm like I don't want to
let down the people who chose this or
now expectations are that much higher
for what I need to do or I just wanna
you know if the world has given me
something I want to give it back ten
times that so I would say that success
can actually be very motivating to you
know not let the world down in terms of
like it's you've been lucky it's it's
blessed you how do you give it back how
do you pay for it
and it's not just being more successful
it's also like literally how do you give
it back
how do you put goodness into the world
how do you give it away that's really
really key to balance and importance the
if I have something I'll just give a
little tip when I have a grind like I
said I've reviewed 22,000 applications
there's about 600 waiting in the queue
right now I need to look at well there's
something that is a long task and it was
gonna take more than a few hours I need
to get through I have to break it up
using the Pomodoro Technique sometimes I
do 25 minutes on five minutes off so I
actually do a longer version where I do
sort of fifty to fifty-five minutes on
and then like ten minutes off because I
find that I can really stay in the flow
for a longer period of time if I have
the right music on and everything like
that so that is something I used to get
through a grind when maybe I don't have
that motivation because let's be honest
like no one including myself wakes up
every morning of every single day being
like ah great sometimes you wake up
those mornings
maybe you mixed your alcohols like I
talked about earlier and you just don't
want to do anything so but you know kind
of something like a Pomodoro Technique
or forcing yourself to you know stare at
the blank page and start typing just
reverse or whatever it is to kind of get
the engine started um can just help it
on those days when you have no
motivation which happen more frequently
than any of us would care to admit
Brian cap asked what has been the
biggest technical problem we've had to
overcome and how did you end up solving
it this is an interesting one because I
thought about it all the technical
problems that I faced in my career in
terms of like a really difficult bit of
code or an upgrade path or you'll bring
in WYSIWYG to WordPress and easy sort of
things are fundamentally tractable
meaning that you can like you can
essentially chip away at it enough that
they're solvable or you get the right
people involved or whatever it is that
there's certainly been fun ones like I
think back to
there's a great presentation by a
wordpress contributor Andrew Nason it
talks about when we added emoji support
into WordPress
it was actually kind of a behind the
scenes essentially way for we found a
really key security problem in
underlying database which was my sequel
that affected not just us but like
everyone out there and the way that we
deal with multi by characters so this is
kind of technical but like normal ASCII
text is represented by a single byte and
a Unicode which is the system which
allows representing you know every
language in the world and also things
like emoji are multi bytes so they might
be two or four bytes long and there was
just a really obscure bug that allowed
you to essentially do some security
exploits by changing how multiple bike
characters were translated and anyway it
was honestly a ton of fun really cool
but because the Verona builder was so
widespread including just not just
WordPress is we want to give people a
chance to upgrade before then so what we
framed as emoji support was actually
this Unicode fix essentially um which
was funny because we had a lot of
criticism people like why are you
putting emojis in when there's bigger
things to work on little did they know
so if you're a super geek and into it if
anything I just said made sense or
seemed interesting check out Nathan's
presentation there you'll enjoy it but
when I think of biggest problems it's
always the people yeah I talked about
WYSIWYG earlier when we brought in the
WYSIWYG editing the WordPress which now
seems like a very non-controversial
feature the timing was very
controversial and people the people side
of it was way more difficult than
navigating the technical side you know
the fact that I studied political
science in college I think has been way
more useful to me than if I'd done
computer science because I don't mean
you know anything and it's applicable
not just the technology but anything is
about people working together and so
learning how to manage learning how to
communicate all those skills are the
things to kind of go to some earlier
questions like what would you take with
you or what would you tell you earlier
yourself for
you're doing something else you know
finally that's the skill which I think
I'm gonna use the rest of my life and
continue to grow and develop the rest of
my life it's not any language I know
today or any field knowledge expertise
or domain expertise
it's just that working with other human
beings and becoming better at it which
is the thing I probably especially a CEO
I think about and try to work on every
day is it's kind of the fun part right
because you think about it most of the
most all fun activities evolve at least
one other person so if you can interact
better with other humans
you know life gets better and the final
question is we end up about one hour
into this from sassari rookie
what is your evening routine parentheses
if you have one this is a cool one and I
like Sassari that you put in that if you
have one because this is where I'll just
be open and honest and vulnerable I'd
like to say that I have a cool evening
routine the reality is that for whatever
reason the way that I currently work
right now and live is that like I kind
of go until the gas tank is empty and
the whether that's working whether
that's with friends or whatever and then
I within a short period of time run out
of gas and I just fall asleep like I've
been very fortunate that I've never had
trouble sleeping and my head hits the
pillows and you know people have dated
etc they laugh at this they're like
literally your head at the pillow 20
seconds later you were asleep
maybe snoring I don't know it's like
it's like what just happens like you
were talking just seconds ago this
literally happened last night I had four
or five friends over at the conversation
was going great I didn't want to stop
them so I said hey keep going but
yesterday I had a wake up of like 4:00
a.m. to to catch an early flight and get
some work in and some meetings and
things so I was just done even though it
was only 10 or 11 and so I said hey you
know keep going I've got a piece out if
it had been a big party I would have
done the Irish
by where you just kind of like leave
without talking anyone there's just four
of us I said hey keep going and I fell
asleep they were still having a great
time and I kind of had hit the at the
end of the road so that's my evening
routine is passing out so I don't know
if that's super useful but I have
thought a lot about morning routine and
this is the latest iteration which I
think I've talked about before this is
latest I still use a coach taught me
which is the app where you can check
things off everyday it's like a daily
to-do list and the things I try to do
every single morning are I try to do
reading in the morning thirty least
thirty minutes of reading because I find
that's the time of the day where where I
kind of have the most engaged after that
is I take my vitamins and bills so
that's Elysium which is well you can
just google it I take some of the the
Nutri box once so like rise and Kato and
then just some other stuff whatever tim
has me taken at that time so like some
ubiquinol ginseng whatever it is kind of
honestly I didn't used to care about
this stuff as much
LM in my thirties vigor hey can't hurt
might help and I'll do whatever Tim
saying most recently I checked it a
little bit of exercise so that's up
right now it's plank I do a plank first
then I do squats and do push-ups then I
do some Sun Salutations to kind of
stretch things out again I'm not super
into yoga but I do a few Sun Salutations
every single day it's amazing
finally I meditate for at least 10
minutes is an app for that called calm C
L C ALM and then yeah when I then I look
at my computer I try to do a blog post
at least four or five days out of the
week
so essentially you could translate this
into writing that I would say is my
perfect morning
now how many mornings do I hit all was
that three six eight of those things not
all of them fewer than I would care to
admit but to me that has been the
current recipe for a thing that just
works the best so on that note I will
leave all of the amazing tim pocket
listeners you're all are a super cool
group I'm excited and honored and thank
you to Tim for a long way to connect
with y'all again and I can't wait to see
the comments and tweets and everything
that come out of this so I'm happy to
engage with y'all again I'm Matt
Mullenweg
my Twitter is at photo Matt phot oh ma
TT you can see me blogging at Mac blog
or at MIT and I'm on Facebook as well
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday if that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the other world of the esoteric as I
do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
for places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc
I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it and here's why
the value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get fifteen
thousand dollars managed for free if you
decide to open an account but just start
with seeing the portfolio that they
would suggest for you take two minutes
fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of this episode is brought
to you by video specifically a new
offering called Vimeo business I've done
a lot of collaboration with these guys
Vimeo business has all of the prior
benefits of Vimeo Pro including VIP
support whether you make videos for a
living
run your
own company like yours truly or simply
want to amp up your video marketing
video business is here to help they have
more than 280 million creators and
viewers worldwide and Vimeo business
makes it easier to share your videos
with a global audience and connect with
professional video makers to bring your
stories to life so if you need
assistance it's there you can also
upload up to 5 terabytes and store your
videos in one secure place you can add
up to 10 team members to your account
for easy collaboration and gather
feedback with seamless review tools you
can add clickable calls to action and
press most interesting to me a capture
email addresses directly in the player
this can help you generate leads and
drive conversion for whatever you are
trying to optimize say for a newsletter
or in fact a sales page of some type
video business helps you optimize your
videos by tracking your engagement and
drop-off so you can then modify your
approach or creative moving forward and
improve it and it connects to Google
Analytics for even more insights let's
check it out go to Vimeo com forward
slash Tim 10 to save 10% on Vimeo
business that's vimeo.com /ti m10
you